[Music]
when people think of the extraordinary
breakthroughs that are made in cancer
research
they don't realize the harmony that
takes place behind that research
in music this only happens when notes
work together
build off each other and combine to
create the perfect harmony
[Music]
in cancer research data pieced together
in a specific way
can lead to new discoveries and
treatments for cancer
now thanks to the nci cancer research
data commons
or crdc sharing data is becoming more
harmonious than ever before
crdc is hitting the right notes
providing access to many
types of data
genomic
proteomic imaging
clinical trial and more
all in one place it is enhancing the way
data are shared
through a single cloud-based and
expandable infrastructure
one that empowers researchers to perform
at peak
by working in real time to explore and
analyze data
without the downtime of downloading and
equips them
with a computational power that only
comes with a cloud
crdc increases connectivity allowing
researchers
access to standardize and harmonize data
to ask more complex research questions
by combining diverse data types across
the crdc
or with their own for integrative
analysis to increase our knowledge about
cancer
all further supporting the goals of
precision medicine
all furthering the effort to accelerate
biomedical discoveries
without missing a beat the crdc gives
researchers a place
where they can work in concert in sync
and in harmony now that's music to many
people's ears
national cancer institute cancer.gov
1-800 for cancer august 2020